hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the melt weather champions
chester finals uh it's youngshish of
duda versus magnus carlsen this is the
second game of their match and it's the
game you guys have been requesting even
more than the first game and for good
reason so let's just dive straight into
it and see if duda can bounce back after
a loss in round one against magnus so do
that with the white pieces opens with d4
sorry about that
we have knight to f6 by magnus c4 and
now g6 the king's indian defense with f3
uh going for the sort of an alien
anti-groomfield variation uh d6 and now
e4 grabbing the the full center we have
e5 now striking in the center
and here just knight to e2 here offering
a queen trade with this doesn't really
do anything this is perfectly fine and
white really doesn't achieve anything by
doing this so just knight to a2 by duda
and now c5 going after that center uh
duda close to the center with the d5 and
now h5 by magnus and now uh there are a
couple of moves that have reached reach
this position for example knight beat
the c there is a known move h4 is a
known move alexander grisham defeated
yani issue with h4 here but here we have
knight e the c3 and it is now as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so let's see how magnus continues here
he plays knight beat to d7 also just
continues development now knight to a3
now this knight can come to c2 then to
e3 and then
later on we'll be controlling a lot of
very important squares here so h4 magnus
grabs more space here on the king side
and bishop to g5 by duda we have bishop
to e7 uh and now bishop back to e3
bishop to e7 is setting a trap for white
basically if white just continues
developing with something like bishop to
d3 uh we can go for a sort of a all-out
trade with knight captures on d5 and
then white loses all advantage of the
first move for example bishop captures
an e7 we're going to capture on c3 now
offer a queen trade and you really don't
have anything better here bishop
captures we're going to play knight
captures on d1 rook captures we're going
to play king captures and black is up
upon
uh white doesn't really have anything to
show for his position if anything he has
a light square bishop and all of his
pawns are on light squares uh so it's a
pretty pretty bad position for white so
instead bishop backed the e3 by dooda
not allowing this exchange and now a6 by
magnus we have queen to d2 and now
knight to h7 now you can push uh push f5
if you want you can castle uh you can
bring the knight to g5 the bishop g5
anything is possible here so g3 by duda
and now knight to g5 so what do you play
here we have queen to g2 now guarding
that f3 pawn knight captures an f3 was a
threat
and now you have to consider do you want
to go for something like h3 here seems
like a very interesting move but magnus
wants to keep the tension here between
these pawns and plays f5 he wants to
open up lines uh we have bishop to d3
and now magnus advances the pawn all the
way to f4 so what do you play here uh
the problem is if something like e
captures e captures and bishop captures
you can just castle here and again it's
a really really bad position for for
white your bishop is hanging here and
after bishop captures bishop captures
it's just a wonderful position from for
black the white king is stuck in the
center of the board you can't castle
queen side so it would definitely be
black who would have advantage here the
f3 pawn is really weak so not something
you want to go for so instead duda moves
the bishop back bishop to d2 and now h3
by magnus now grabbing more space here
queen to e2 and now only now does he
castle king's side
we have rook to g1 dude of course now is
interested in opening up the g file uh
to be used for this rook and now rook to
f7 by magnus we have queen side castles
duda brings his king to safety and now
queen to f8 so now you have to be
careful if the position opens up then
the f3 pawn really becomes weak so rook
d to f1 and now queen to g7 uh and now
it's time to start bringing our other
knight into the game it's not really
doing all that much on a3 knights the c2
by duda and now comes knight to f8 uh so
here we have king to b1 getting the king
to uh to a safer square knight after h7
by magnus we have knight to e1 as we
often say a lot of horsing around
and bishop to d7 it's time to bring the
other rook into the game as well we have
bishop to c2 and now rook a to f8 so a
lot of maneuvering preparing for that uh
breakthrough that will definitely happen
as there is a lot of tension in the
position so here we have g captures on
f3 by duda we have e captures on f sorry
on f4 e captures on f4 and now knight to
d3 so putting some pressure on this f4
pawn but it's nicely defended by the two
rooks
and now bishop to f6 by magnus so what
do you play here uh now it seems like
magnus is offering the f4 pawn uh but if
you've seen game one you know that uh
there really aren't uh you know such
things as free gifts when playing
against magnus however duda tries it he
plays bishop captures on f4 and okay
magnus plays bishop captures on c3 now
opening up a discovery here towards the
bishop
and the problem is if you play this then
this is just perfectly fine captures
captures and captures and black is just
much much better here you don't really
have all that much you have a knight uh
basically two knights for a rook this is
completely winning for black so duda
here plays bishop captures and d6 now
puts pressure on the rook on f8 but now
bishop the d4 attacking the rook and g1
so what do you play here uh well there
are a lot of possibilities of course we
could capture the the rook on f8 but the
duda tries f4 first
he attacks the knight here on g5 and now
magnus just captures the rook he plays
bishop captures on g1
and now what do you play well
the position is very very promising for
white black's position is active but
white's position is active and better
but you have to play rook captures on g1
however aduda decided to throw in a nice
swish and sook here
but that simply will not do bishop to e5
was played attacking carlson's queen
but magnus as you've seen does not have
a problem offering his queen so uh first
he just plays uh knight to f6 so for the
moment uh it's still um
uh
well the the reason uh knight to f6 was
played is because it's maybe a little
bit difficult to calculate but rook
captures on f4 and the queen can be
offered right away the problem is if
bishop captures on g7 now rook captures
an f1 check and that's it you don't
really have a good move bishop to d1
we're just going to play king captures
on d7 and the position is completely
winning for black black has simply too
much material and
well there there's really nothing to do
here with white uh so what you could do
here
uh is uh what magnus uh well you could
do that but magnus played knight to f6
first he prepares this idea and now duda
allows it by playing a certain move here
you could play let's say bishop captures
on f6 queen captures and rook captures
on g1 and the game continues however
after this knight to f6 a move by magnus
duda played f captures on g5 and now it
seems like a perfectly winning idea
because now you're attacking the pin
piece but now feel free to pause the
video and win the game for magnus while
i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on now offering
the queen
finally and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's knight to g4
that's the good stuff we offer the queen
uh not only that we attacked the bishop
twice and not only that we're
threatening rook captures on f1 so what
can you what can you make of this well
if the queen is accepted then rook
captures an f1 check and there's nothing
to be done here bishop to d1 king
captures and g7 similar to the queen
sacrifice we already discussed but here
for example e5 uh
going for something like e6 we're just
gonna play knight to e3 and there's no
defense uh the bishop cannot move you
can bring more defenders here if e6 we
just trade here rook captures on d1
queen captures knight captures and now
let's see captures on d7 but it's not a
problem i mean we're we're up a rook in
the bishop and this pawn will never do
anything we can just pick it up so black
is completely winning here so after
knight to g4 we have bishop the f6 by
duda preventing the these two rooks from
wreaking havoc along the ef file but now
just uh bishop captures an h2 by magnus
he says all right i grabbed the pawn i'm
going to move my bishop and then i'm
going to advance my pass pawn and this
is now a really dangerous pass pawn so
e5 by duda but now just knight captures
on f6 we have e captures on f6 and now
magnus uh offers it again he plays dasha
back to d6 and now the pawn is going to
h2 the problem is uh the same again if
you capture the queen just rook captures
on f1 check and now let's say knight to
c1 or bishop to d1 doesn't really matter
if bishop to d1 king captures and g7 is
completely winning for black but if
knight to c1 uh we can just uh even
bring the rook here and what do you do
if queen to e4 we're just gonna play
bishop to f4 and there is no defense
here this is now completely winning for
black so really a terrible position for
white so after this bishop to d6 move we
have knights to f4 by duda
but now there is only one winning move
for black and it's not easy to spot so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for magnus now while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on sacrificing
something anything is there you know
there are so many things we could
sacrifice here but only one is good so
congratulations to everyone who founded
the correct move is rook captures on f6
that's the good stuff we keep control of
this f file and we remove any pressure
that white had over our position so g
captures on f6 is played
it's not much but you don't really have
anything better we have rook captures on
f6 now with a double attack on the
knight here and knight to e6 by duda
seems like everything is now fine but
here comes rook captures on f1 queen
captures on f1 and now queen to h6 and
now the problem white's been having for
the entire game pretty much is still
here the the past pawn on h3 is
unstoppable so here we have queen to f6
uh what do you do here well just h2
this is unstoppable now h1 queen is
coming uh we have bishop to e for
stopping this uh where at least
for the moment but still just h1 queen
we have bishop captures queen captures
with check king to c2 and the knock
comes queen to e4 check and he was in
this position on 41 that young shisht of
duda resigned to the game and another
impressive victory for magnus carlsen in
round two of the meltweather champions
chester finals
uh so here you resign uh because there
really isn't anything for you to do the
g6 pawn is defended there are no uh
well there's really nothing you can play
if you try something like uh
oh you're in check you can't even try
that uh you have to move the king so
king to d2 now we simply capture here
and that's it uh
whatever d captures on e6 we're gonna
play bishop to f4 check king to c3 and
now let's say bishop to e5 wins the
queen or you know whatever
there is no playing this position
uh
whatever you do you're just gonna get
destroyed uh if you play some like king
to d1 it's a very nice checkmating
sequence queen to d3 king the e1 we're
going to play bishop to g3 just cover
all of the squares as you can see the
queen and bishop are doing a fine job of
this uh you have to interpose with the
queen now we're gonna play queen e3
check first so we we take the queen
without giving up the bishop king d1
let's say the queen captures an f2 and
that's it there's there's no uh playing
this so after queen to e4 do the resigns
and the game two seems to be an even
more impressive version of game one uh
so we'll see if duda will be able to
bounce back two more games to go in the
match uh we'll we'll see what happens uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it so many of you have requested
it and for good reasons as usual please
uh keep doing that uh i would like to
thank zachary bell uh mike pomeraning
vast knowledge the duty dewey guy and
tom derral of her contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of this
tournament as all of the games seem uh
well incredible
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day